c'était un lundi cette nuit là le 11
septembre 1944 les allemands fui dijon
au petit matin les forces de la
résistance à bord de camions les ffi et
la première armée française du général
de lattre de tassigny entre par la route
de plombières après des combats autour
de la ville
objectif des français empêcher les
soldats de la wehrmacht de s'échapper
vers le nord par la trouée de belfort
vers 8 heures du matin nous entrions
dans dijon phare la rue général
fauconnet qui lui valent saison qu'elle
a derrière et quand même des camarades
qui ont été tuées à côté de moi et ça
reste marquée dans une vie jane mais par
contre la libération n'a été reçue les
bras ouverts on était de livrer
libérateur dijon libéré
c'est l'effervescence les pancartes
allemands sont enlevées place darcy une
foule en liesse célèbre la fin de quatre
années d'occupation qui ont laissé des
traces
quelques jours plus tôt les allemands
ont bombardé et totalement détruit la
gare deux jours après la libération les
troupes françaises défilent entre la
place darcy et l'hôtel de ville dijon
devient symbole dans la marche
victorieuse de l'armée du maréchal de
lattre de tassigny